Nancy Pelosi battles her radical flank
president Trump comes under attack from
his own base and the battle for the tech
world continues i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
now I know if you're watching us right
now you are thinking from where are you
broadcasting and the answer is from Ann
Arbor Michigan because I'm speaking at
University of Michigan tonight it should
be fun they're a bunch of counter
protests that are planned including
apparently a musical about me which
sounds more interesting frankly than my
speech like I would actually attend that
thing because number one I'm deeply
narcissistic and number two I like
musicals so I'm totally into it we'll
get to more on what's going to happen
University of Michigan tonight a little
bit later on in the show first let us
talk about your sleep quality so you've
thought about your mattress you've
thought about what temperature you
wanted in your room you've thought about
everything except for your sheets
because who thinks about your sheets
right I mean just went down to the local
shop and you picked up whatever sheets
were available and it said high thread
count whoo that means soft it does not
mean soft what you need our Bowl and
branch sheets everything Bowl and branch
makes from betting to blankets is made
from pure 100% organic cotton which
means they start out super soft they get
even softer over time you buy direct
from them so you're essentially paying
wholesale prices luxury sheets can cost
up to $1,000 in the store but Boleyn
brand sheets are only a couple of
hundred bucks everybody who tries Boleyn
brand sheets loves them that's why they
have thousands of five-star reviews
Forbes The Wall Street Journal Fast
Company they are all talking about bull
and branch even three u.s. presidents
sleep on bull and branch sheets shipping
is free you can try them for 30 nights
if you don't love them send them back
for a refund but you're not gonna want
to send them back there is no risk and
no reason do not give them a try to get
you started right now my listeners get
50 bucks off your first set of sheets at
bull and branch calm promo code Bend
that is a Bo LL and branch calm promo
code Ben for 50 bucks off your first set
of sheets they're so comfortable my wife
and I got rid of all the other sheets in
our house after we tried Mullen branch
you will to Bowl and branch calm promo
code Ben Bo LL and branch calm promo
code Ben ok so I want to get some
serious news in a second but first I
have to apprise you of a couple of very
important news items just off the hot
the wires so the President of the United
States has issued an official
proclamation his official proclamation
concerns airplanes so as you know
there's a terrible airplane crash from
Ethiopia airlines kept like 150 people
it was the second Boeing model to go
down as a new model second Boeing model
to go down in a matter of last six
months President Trump has some thoughts
because President Trump I know you may
not have known this president Trump is
secretly an aerospace engineer and so
the president
tweeted this out today in all of his
wisdom quote airplanes are becoming far
too complex to fly pilots are no longer
needed but rather computer scientists
from MIT I see it all the time in many
products are we seeking to go one
unnecessary step further when often and
simpler is far better split-second
decisions are needed and the complexity
creates danger all of this for great
cost yet very little gain I don't know
about you but I don't want Albert
Einstein to be my pilot I want great
flying professionals that are allowed to
easily and quickly take control of a
plane Thank You mr. president for that
announcement on the engineering of
airplane you know not unprecedented the
fact is that Abraham Lincoln had some
really deep thoughts about the mechanics
of trains actually back in like 1862 so
I guess this it's not unusual for the
presidents of the United States to tweet
out about airplanes it is worth noting
that last year he did tweet out that
thanks to him there had been no
commercial airline fatalities that year
so I'm not sure what that means for the
president again like is this important
no it's not important it's silly but
that's the point he's the President of
the United States should he stop
tweeting about why biplanes are better
than fixed-wing aircraft probably should
he stop tweeting about Albert Einstein
being the pilot of his plane like
somewhere Elon Musk is sitting there
nodding and smoking a joint it's a solid
stuff from Trump right there meanwhile
in other stupid news you know because
you know the news is too serious lately
and honestly I'd rather discover stupid
news for a moment so in other stupid
news Felicity Huffman and Lori Loughlin
are among actresses CEOs charged an
alleged to college admissions scam so
this is a mad lib headline from an
alternative reality Felicity Huffman who
you'll remember from Desperate
Housewives and Lori Loughlin from Full
House have now been charged for
utilizing a service that basically
bribed people to get you into college
according to ABC News actresses and
chief executives are among 50 people
arrested in the nationwide college
admissions cheating scam authorities
announced on Tuesday according to
charging documents actresses Felicity
Huffman and Lori Loughlin are among
those involved facing charges the
suspects allegedly paid bribes of up to
six million dollars to get their kids
into elite colleges including Yale
Stanford Georgetown and USC
one of those things is not like the
others and not listen my sister went to
USC I'm see UCLA Homer okay in most
cases the students did not know their
admission was contingent on a bribe
University athletic coaches and
administrators of college entrance exams
were also among those arrested
first of all worth noting if you paid
like six million dollars to get your kid
into college your kids didn't need to be
pay even need to pay six million dollars
to get your kid into college first of
all you just given get some sort of
donation to the school and they'd like
your kid and second of all you have six
million dollars couldn't you put your
money in a trust fund and let your kid
be an arrow do well like all other rich
parents
well ABC News says the alleged scam
centered around a man in California who
ran a business helping students get into
the College of their choice
authorities say parents would pay him a
predetermined amount with full knowledge
of what they were doing he would then
steer the money to one of two places
either an SAT or a CT administrator or a
college athletic coach the coaches would
allegedly arrange a fake profile that
listed the prospective student as an
athlete and examined ministers would
either hire Proctor's to take the test
or correct the answers of a student the
bribes range from a few thousand dollars
up to six million dollars according to
officials and the charging documents
unsealed in Boston federal court are
more than two hundred pages long I would
like to find out how these kids actually
did at these colleges seriously because
if your kid like got like an eleven
hundred on the SATs and then you bribe
people to get them into Yale did they
fail out if they did not fail out Yale
isn't doing its job according to the
authorities
Felicity Huffman and her husband made a
purported charitable contribution of 15
grand to participate in the college
entrance exam cheating scheme on behalf
of her eldest daughter Huffman later
made arrangements to pursue a scheme for
a second time for her younger daughter
before deciding not to do so federal
agents say they have recorded telephone
calls with Huffman and a cooperating
witness the documents say that Laughlin
and her husband agreed to pay bribes
totaling five hundred thousand dollars
in exchange for having their two
daughters designated as recruits to the
USC crew team despite the fact they did
not participate in Cru thereby
facilitating their admission to USC
officials say they have emails from
Laughlin okay
first of all if you are paying like 15
grand to get into Yale at least I
understand that if you're paying half a
million dollars to get into USC again
not to rip on USC but come on gang
$500,000 to pay to get into USC I mean
that's like paying $200 for a Big Mac
okay listen I us he's great
have a lot of friends at USC there's a
person in the room from USA who right
now is on the verge of coming over and
strangling me I'll just say that that is
not getting your money's worth right
there you just been half a million
dollars you at least one an ivy-league
right I mean at least you want to get
into like lower Ivy League like brown or
something I mean come on that's that's
absurd okay fine so in real news I know
I know in real news
Nancy Pelosi is now at war with her own
base now this has been a long time in
coming Nancy Pelosi being at war with
her base you knew this was coming
because ever since the election of 2018
there have been some fresh faces very
fresh as well as incredibly face and
those fresh faces have made clear that
they see themselves as in control of the
direction of the future Congress and
Nancy Pelosi has been playing the
appeasement game she's basically been
feeding pieces of the party to these
people in the hopes that they will eat
her last but they're not interested in
eating her last they're interested in
using her as their meat puppet they
would prefer to use her as sort of the
puppet they put their hand behind her
head and they make her voice her voice
come out but they are saying aoc words
which means a lot of likes and hums well
now speaker Pelosi has run afoul of this
group of people that listen she was
willing to go so far as to let them off
the hook for blatant anti-semitism she
was willing to water down a resolution
to not include the name Ilhan Omar she
was willing to water down the resolution
to not only deal with anti-semitism she
was willing to go out of her way not to
tap even love tap these these young
fresh faces so as to prove to them that
she was actually in control and now they
are coming for her they are coming for
her because she has said the unsayable
they're not going to impeach President
Trump oh I know I know so according to
the New York Post House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi announced on Monday that she's
against impeaching President Trump
unless there's something so compelling
and overwhelming and bipartisan okay
well it's that last it's that last
statement bipartisan that got her in
trouble because everybody knows the
Republicans are not going to sign on to
an attempt to impeach President Trump
it's not going to happen there weren't
any Democratic votes to impeach Bill
Clinton back in the day the speaker is
surely up to speed on what evidence
Democrats actually
have against Trump and has a fair sense
of what special counsel Bob Muller's
report will say according to the Post
editorial board
she recognizes it's nothing that will
persuade anyone who hasn't wanted Trump
now stood since Election Day 2016 see
this is Nancy Pelosi being smart because
Nancy Pelosi recognizes that if in fact
it looks like a witch-hunt
if in fact it looks like she's trying to
impeach Trump for non crimes that's
gonna tick off an awful lot of people a
lot of people are gonna say well this
seems unfair Trump is going to loudly
proclaim that he's being targeted for
unfair reasons moderates who are not
interested in a prolonged impeachment
spiel are going to get uptight with
Nancy Pelosi and the Democrats she knows
that because she is not a dum-dum
unfortunately there are members of her
base who in fact are dum-dums and
they're very angry at her very angry at
her so that means that they are going to
be attacking her now what's funny is
that again the most militant people when
it comes to the Mullen report even they
are looking forward to the Mellow report
and saying I don't think that what we've
been saying is there is actually going
to be there one of those people is Adam
Schiff the representative from my
district in California Adam shift Adam
Schiff who literally has a pup tent set
up outside the greenroom at CNN so he
can talk about Russia just any time of
the day
then Comelec one o'clock in the morning
and boom he's on a rerun of of exploring
the world with with w kamau Bell he just
sort of pops in to talk about Russia for
no reason at any time in the mornings I
go brief update on Russia call Adam
Schiff he's right outside
well even Adam Schiff is saying well
yeah I'm not sure that we're gonna be
able to do this impeachment thing we
don't have Senate support in the absence
of very graphic evidence it would be
difficult to get the support in the
Senate needed to make an impeachment
successful so again you know my feeling
is let's see what Bob Weller produces
but the evidence will have to be pretty
overwhelming okay so that is not
actually going to happen but this has
ticked off the Democratic base the
Democratic base is very angry at Nancy
Pelosi the fresh faces of the Democratic
base have come out and said that this is
very bad we have to impeach Trump don't
you understand he's the most dangerous
man alive so they're not wrong here's
the thing they're not wrong given the
rhetoric of people like Nancy Pelosi if
in fact Donald Trump is the most
dangerous man alive if in fact he
an incipient Hitler then you have to get
him out of office by any means necessary
no matter what you must get rid of him
that's that's the idea from the fresh
faces and the fresh faces again are not
incorrect in their assessments of the
situation and as we'll see they are not
shy about suggesting such they're not
try about saying that sort of thing
we'll get to that in just a second first
let's talk about how you send packages
no one really has time to go to the post
office you're busy who has time for
traffic parking lugging all your mail
and packages it is indeed a real hassle
that's why you need stamps calm it's one
of the most popular time-saving tools
for small businesses stamps.com
eliminates trips to the post office and
saves you money with discounts you can't
even get at the post office stamps.com
brings all the amazing services of the
US Postal Service directly to your
computer whether you're a small office
sending invoices or an online sellers
shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps.com can handle it all with
ease you can simply use your computer to
print official US postage 24/7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just hands it over to your
mail carrier or drop it in a mailbox it
is indeed that simple with stamps comm
you get five cents off every first-class
stamp and up to 40% off Priority Mail
not to mention it's a fraction of the
cost of those expensive postage meter
stamps com is a no-brainer saves you
time saves you money
it's no wonder 700,000 small businesses
are to use it right now my listeners get
a special offer it includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Shapiro that is stamps comm
enter Shapiro and get that special deal
four week trial plus free postage and
digital scale no long-term commitment
stamps comm enter Shapiro the post
office is great no need to wait in line
check the mount stamps calm and type in
Shapiro at checkout alrighty so the
Democrats are upset rightly so with
Nancy Pelosi it turns out that when you
pitch your base on we have to get rid of
Hitler they sort of want you to get rid
of Hitler and this is why so many folks
in the radical base are resonating to
people like Oh Hannah Marceau Ilhan Omar
yesterday was asked about the fact that
she'd said some pretty nasty things
about Barack Obama
she made a boo-boo she talked to
Politico and in her interview with
Politico she said that Barack Obama was
I kid you not a murderer with a pretty
face she said that in her interview with
Politico then she tried to back off from
that and say no no I didn't mean that at
all should I even
recording to prove that I was misquoted
then she released the recording and it
showed that she said exactly what she
was quoted as saying so she doesn't
understand how recordings work also the
Jews must have gotten to that recording
obviously I mean there's only one answer
there so now she says listen when I said
that Obama isn't human or that he's a
murderer
that's not right he's not a murderer
I'll tell you who's the real murderer
I'll say who's the real inhuman person
that of course is present in Trump you
just think that he's more she is such an
angry person I mean just to forget about
you know the suggestion is that if you
say that that Ilhan Omar is angry that
this is some sort of racial slur no
she's just an angry person there are
lots of black folks who are not angry
she's a Somali woman who happens to be a
very angry person every time you see her
on tape she's being an angry person
every single time there's a member of
the media asking her a perfectly normal
question about something that she says
and she starts sneering at them and then
she spits the answer at them as though
she's angry at them there's nothing
abnormal about asking her about
something she said to Politico to a
reporter but here's the real key she
says Trump isn't even a human being
so she compared Obama to Trump she said
basically they're the same except Obama
was prettier and now she's backtracking
by saying Trump isn't even human well if
you believe Trump isn't human then why
wouldn't you want to impeach him if you
believe that he's a space alien sent to
destroy the earth presumably you'd be in
favor of impeachment so Nancy Pelosi has
now run afoul of her own base she's run
a fad and you're seeing it on Twitter
you're seeing people on the Left saying
Nancy Pelosi has been bought and paid
for
something's happened to Nancy what
happened to woke Nancy here's the deal
Nancy Pelosi when you flirt with the
radicals in your party eventually they
behead you that's what happens with
every revolution robes pr1 to the
guillotine you lead the revolution you
may not end up with your head outside
the bucket that's the way this works now
the Democrats are in fact struggling
against
in a second well gets that the Democrats
are struggling against this so for
example you got Stinney Hoyer standing
Hoyer is the house minority Majority
Whip and he was specifically asked about
the new faces the ill Hannah Mars and
the Rashida to leaves and the Ocasio
cortezes and he says listen I got plenty
of other people here who are represented
by this party why are we being dictated
to by these particular ones he says
quote we've got 62 new Democratic
members not three so he and and Pelosi
are trying to dismiss the power of these
new members but the problem is those
three new members are getting all the
media and the reason they're getting all
the media is because the media actually
agree with these three new members the
media would like to see president Trump
impeached this is the problem if you
live inside the Washington DC New York
Beltway bubble and I'm not just talking
about people who are members of
government I'm talking about members of
the media if you live inside that bubble
then you and everyone you know believe
that President Trump is an evil man and
you believe that the Russians stole the
election and this is why the coverage on
CNN doesn't seem to reflect what the
American people want to hear about very
much it's why the ratings aren't very
good instead it seems to reflect the
sensibilities of people who spend all
day ensconced in this stuff and deeply
worried about the evils of President
Trump well who mirrors those worries
more than Ilhan Omar and Rasheeda Talib
and AOC the answer is none of them I
mean none of these other 62 members
mirror those worries better and so Nancy
Pelosi has a problem Nancy Pelosi
Believe It or Not understands the voter
in Ohio better than the reporters on CNN
Nancy Pelosi understands the voters in
Ohio
better than Rasheeda Talib who is from
Michigan or L hen Omar who is from
Minnesota or a OC these are all from
extraordinarily blue districts in which
all their supporters Pat them on the
back for saying incredibly radical
things they are in bubbles Nancy Pelosi
is in a bubble of her own in San
Francisco but Nancy Pelosi hasn't
actually been the representative from
San Francisco for a long time she's been
at the head of the Democratic Party
establishment in the house in the House
of Representatives she'd in the head of
it since 2006 she's been in that
position of power for 12 years that's a
long time to hear from various Congress
people all over America and what their
constituents are looking for but what
those people are looking for may in fact
be at war with the radicals and this is
a problem not only for Democrats in
Congress
problem for Democrats across the board
for example in the 2020 election it
means that anybody who's perceived as
even remotely moderate is immediately
going to be cast out that's why I think
that right now Bernie Sanders is the
leader coming round the turn in the
Democratic primaries now it's still very
early obviously a lot can happen but
there are a lot of folks who are trying
to say that Joe Biden is the guy who's
going to take the nomination I don't see
that I don't see Joe Biden taking the
nomination I think he'd be the one who
did I think they'd be smart to nominate
Joe Biden I think if you're talking
about somebody who is most likely to win
Pennsylvania Michigan and Wisconsin all
three states Democrats need to win if if
I think that that Biden is the guy who's
most likely to win those states but the
problem is Biden is not the guy who's
most likely to win these primaries his
best day will be the first day he
declares the day that Joe Biden declares
there will be all sorts of media he'll
see a little bump in the polls he'll go
up from whatever it is 28% to 33% and
then he'll start coming down again why
because he's apt to be torn apart by
both the progressive wing and the
intersectional wing of the Democratic
Party leading the the battle on the
intersectional side is Jamelle Bouie
Jamelle Bouie is a columnist formerly
for slate now for the New York Times he
has a column today called the trouble
with Biden and it is a good reminder of
why it is that the Democrats are
unlikely to nominate somebody like Joe
Biden who's in any way moderate here's
what Jamelle Bouie writes he says as
they begin their search for a nominee
most Democrats prize electability above
all else they want a sure thing someone
who will be President Trump but beating
Trump isn't the same as beating Trump
ISM unseating the president won't
automatically undermine the white
resentment and racial chauvinism that
drive his movement that will depend on
the nature of the campaign against him
and whether it challenges the
assumptions of his ideology or affirms
them in the name of electoral pragmatism
so this is Jamelle Bouie making the case
against joe biden by basically saying
that biden is another trump when it
comes to issues of race again Biden is
gonna get savaged on all sides here guys
his his association with President Obama
will not save him and the chances that
Obama endorses him in a primary are
exceedingly low Jamelle Bouie says the
possibility of defeating Trump without
defeating Trump ISM looms over Joe
Biden's possible run for the 2020
Democratic nomination
the former VP's not yet candidacy
centers on his appeal to the white Luke
our workers who rejected Hillary Clinton
in favor of Donald Trump he believes he
could have won them in 2016 and he
thinks he can win them now this isn't
just about Biden's working class effect
as a senator from Delaware Biden
understood himself as a staunch defender
of middle American interests but those
interests were racialized which is how a
younger Biden could at once be a
committed liberal and an ardent opponent
of busing to desegregate his state's
public schools so now Jamelle Bouie is
making the case better to lose an
election by ignoring those white
blue-collar folks than to pander to
those white blue-collar folks with
anything approaching moderation and he
uses as his example of Joe Biden being a
racist Biden's opposition to forced
busing now forced busing is battle we
haven't had in the United States for 50
years I mean really this goes back to
the 1960s and 1970s in the aftermath of
Brown versus Board of Education and the
aftermath of the Civil Rights Act there
were a series of pieces of legislation
and court rulings that suggested that
people would be bused from certain
schools to other schools so you wouldn't
actually go to the school in your school
district if your school district was
predominantly black then maybe you would
be bused out from that school district
to a white school district or if there
was a white school district that seemed
to be better than a black school
district in terms of population in in
the in terms of scores for example but I
mean a black school district in terms of
its a population of black students then
you would have white students bused in
from the suburbs to black public schools
now there's a strong case on libertarian
grounds that forcing children to go to
schools where they have no local
connection is actually wrong there's
also a good case on practical grounds
that this actually caused white flight
than what actually happened is that
white folks didn't want their kids going
to worse public schools because it
turned out that a lot of these schools
that were worse in terms of performance
also happen to be heavily minority
thanks to decades of underfunding and
thanks to social problems and all the
rest of this and so a lot of white folks
picked up and they moved out even
further to the suburbs that a cost of
urban sprawl that had caused people to
leave and it didn't actually make the
education system any better but Jamelle
Bouie says that if you opposed forced
busing then you're racist and you were
catering to white racists so he
specifically points out the fact that
Joe Biden in 1975 said I do not buy the
concept popular in the 60s which said we
have suppressed the black man for 300
years and the white man is now far ahead
in the race for everything our society
offers in order to even the score he
must now give the black man a head start
or even hold the white man back to even
the race I don't buy that and and Jamel
Boyce is by and made his argument using
language that is still common to
opponents of efforts to rectify racial
inequality I don't feel responsible for
the sins of my father and grandfather I
feel responsible for the situation today
for the sins of my own generation and
I'll be damned if I feel responsible to
pay for what happened 300 years ago
Jamelle Bouie says busing did its job
integrating schools and improving
outcomes for black students but many
whites viewed it as an encroachment on
the privileges afforded them in a
racially stratified society what W EB Du
Bois called a psychological wage given
as compensation for racial solidarity
these Americans thought they could keep
black children out of their schools and
neighborhoods busing meant they couldn't
and they were angry well know sometimes
busing actually happened in Reverse
sometimes it was white kids being bused
into schools where they didn't have any
friends where they didn't have any
community and the opposition of forced
busing was in part opposition to force
now I'm all in favor of greater racial
integration I'm not in favor of force to
integration there is a difference
between desegregation and forced
integration this was a legitimate
argument it was had in the 60s and the
1970s there's very good book on this by
a legal scholar from the University of
Texas named lino Grazia came out maybe
15 20 years ago in essence the notion
that you oppose forced busing therefore
you are a racist or therefore you are
pandering to racial concerns per se it
doesn't necessarily follow but the point
the broader point for Joe Biden is this
dude's gonna get savaged Joe Biden has a
problem the base of the Democratic Party
is more in line with the views of
Jamelle Bouie and Ilhan Omar and
Rasheeda to leave and Ocasio Cortes than
they are with Joe Biden in just a second
we're gonna talk about how President
Trump has some of these problems of his
own we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about some things in
life that simply aren't right you know
carpet and showers eating dip with your
fingers chunky style milk gross that's
gross stuff but thanks to MIT mobile you
do not have to overpay for Wireless
anymore that would be a bad thing with
mint mobile you can cut your wireless
bill down to just 15 bucks a month
they've reimagined Wireless making it
easy and online only which means they
can pass significant savings directly to
you you can save a thousand plus bucks a
year with mint mobile without
sacrificing quality service they make it
easy to cut your wireless bill down to
just 15 bucks a month use your own phone
with any mint mobile plan you can keep
your old number along with your existing
contacts with mint mobile choose between
plans with 3/8 or
twelve gigabytes of 4G LTE data stop
hang from the minute data that's how the
phone companies get you you may never
use that unlimited data every plan comes
with unlimited nationwide talk and text
and if you're not 100% satisfied mint
mobile has you covered with their seven
day money-back guarantee did your old
wireless bill start saving with mint
mobile you got nothing to lose since
you've got a seven day money back
guarantee to get that new wireless plan
for just fifteen bucks a month and get
the plan shipped to your door for free
go to mint mobile comm slash Ben that is
mint mobile comm slash man cut that
Wireless bill to fifteen bucks a month
get free shipping on your mint mobile
plan at mi NT mobile.com slash Ben that
is mint mobile comm slash man got no
reason for you to be spending exorbitant
dollars on data that you're never going
to use mint mobile can save you money
and again they've got a seven day
money-back guarantee so give it a try
it's not gonna cost you anything if you
don't like it mint mobile comm slash Ben
go check them out right now well
president from theoretically could have
some problems from his own base the
difference is that most people who voted
for President Trump voted to stop
Democrats in the first place Democrats
right now are voting to forward leftist
goals Republicans are voting to stand
athwart the rails of history shouting
stop at radical Democrats and this is
where President Trump has some benefit
this is why Ann Coulter's opposition is
not probably going to have any
significant impact on President Trump so
Ann Coulter is now ripping president
Trump the author of in Trump We Trust is
very angry at him because she says that
he has not fulfilled his promises on
immigration according to the Palm Beach
Post Ann Coulter said it's hard to find
people she can talk to you now that
she's directed her scorching criticism
on President Trump and his failure to
build the us-mexico border wall she said
it's frustrating I can't talk to Trump
detractors because as the subtitle to my
last book indicated they're insane I
can't talk to the Trump flatterers
because they think as soon as it comes
out of his mouth that has happened no
he's an excellent talker it's just when
it comes to doing anything that he falls
down on the job
she said Trump may be a shallow
narcissistic con man but that does not
mean the enemy are not the enemy of the
people both things can be true so she's
been very angry at President Trump he
called her wacky this week he said I
don't know why he doesn't just ignore me
he doesn't mind ignoring the rest of his
base colts are compared Trump to
President George HW Bush who lost in
1992 after not building the wall she did
the first George Bush for example read
my lips no new
access he said one time at the
convention Trump talked about building
the wall at least once a day for 18
months if the wall supporting Trump base
isn't energized in 2020 Coulter said the
nightmare scenario is the Democrats and
they have gone mad they elect somebody
completely crazy just wild left-wing now
here is here's the thing about when
Anna's saying Trump was always
predicated the rise of Trump was always
predicated on the argument that Hillary
would be worse and this is still the
response you get like if you make fun of
Trump tweeting about airplanes you get
what you'd rather have Hillary that's
like no I didn't say I'd rather have
Hillary I think it's funny that Trump is
tweeting about airplane technology get
over it but there is a contingent of
people it's very large and out it's most
of the Republican base that supports
Trump not because they are deeply in
love with everything the President Trump
does but because they wanted to stop
Hillary Clinton and now they can't stand
the cognitive dissonance of he's not
giving them everything they want so a
lot of folks have convinced themselves
that President Trump has already built
the wall that America has already been
made great again and all of the rest
Coulter's please in other words are
falling on deaf ears and this is one of
the problems for actual conservatives
one of the problems for actual
conservatives is that if you are worried
about the forwarding of conservatism the
forwarding of conservatism means more
than simply stopping the left stopping
the left is a worthwhile goal the
radicalism of the left should be stopped
but if you actually want to save
conservatism if you want to promote
conservatism then you have to do more
than simply not doing what the Democrats
want for example you probably shouldn't
be cheering on the president who just
proposed a four point seven five
trillion dollar budget the largest
budget in American history by a longshot
President Trump sent Congress on Monday
they record four point seven five
trillion dollar budget plan that calls
for increased military spending and
sharp cuts to domestic programs like
education and Environmental Protection
for the 2020 fiscal year mr. Trump's
budget the largest in federal history
includes a nearly five percent increase
in military spending more than the
Pentagon had asked for and an additional
eight point six billion dollars for
construction of a wall along the border
with Mexico
this budget like all budgets that have
been submitted for the last decade or so
is dead on arrival Democratic Congress
ain't gonna pass anything like it
it contains what the White House
officials called a total of one point
nine trillion dollars in cost savings
from mandatory safety net programs like
Medicaid and Medicare the federal health
care programs for the elderly and the
or this has caused left to cry that
President Trump is trying to cut
Medicaid and Medicare that is not true
he is growing Medicare and Medicaid but
at slower rates than the left would have
him do one of the trick or pieces of
trickery that you will see from the
mainstream media is they will say that
if I was supposed to spend $200 next
year and instead I spend 150 dollars
next year that I have somehow cut my
spending no because I haven't spent any
of that money yet so I've actually
increased my spending by a hundred and
fifty dollars next year I have not saved
fifty dollars every time the media talk
about savings cost savings by cutting
future spending from expected spending
this is the same as when my wife goes to
Costco buys eight million eight million
paper plates legitimate and like has a
truck come and deliver them and dump
them off and spends 1 million dollars on
these eight million paper plates and
then tells me that she saved me a
million dollars because if she'd bought
the paper plate somewhere else there
would been twice as expensive that's not
how this works
the budget is unlikely to have much
effect on actual spending levels which
are controlled by Congress Democratic
leaders in both the House and Senate
pronounced the budget DOA but the
blueprint is a declaration of trumps
reelection campaign priorities and the
starting skirmish in the race for 2020
frankly I'm not even sure why President
Trump bothered to try and cut future
spending or make cost savings in
Medicare and Medicaid I know why he
bothered to do that so long as we know
the budgets aren't going to pass you
should just propose a 10 trillion dollar
budget and then he can compete with
Democrats then he can say listen I want
to do all the things that you want to do
except I'm not crazy
and he would look saying by contrast but
the point the broader point is this
Trump stopping the left not the same
thing as Trump forwarding good things
and you're seeing that blowback from for
example former Vice President Dick
Cheney Dick Cheney is back on the road
he did a discussion with Vice President
Mike Pence and things started to go
wildly wrong it was a closed-door
retreat hosted by the American
Enterprise Institute in Sea Island
Georgia and Cheney respectfully but
repeatedly and firmly pressed Mike Pence
on a number of the president's foreign
policy moves over which Cheney expressed
concerns from taking a harder line
toward US allies in NATO - deciding to
withdraw troops from Syria during what
Cheney fretted was the middle of a
telephone call Cheney worried aloud to
pence we're getting into a situation
where our friends and allies around the
world that we depend on are going to
lack confidence in US and then offered a
blunt assessment of the current
administration
response to foreign policy challenges
Cheney said I worry that the bottom line
of that kind of an approach is we have
an administration that looks a lot more
like Barack Obama than Ronald Reagan
Cheney's questions for pence provided a
revealing glimpse into the churning and
often strained debates inside the
Republican Party where longtime GOP
Hawks such as Cheney have increasingly
balked at Trump's engagement with
autocrats and his non interventionist
approach to US military efforts in the
Middle East is according to the
Washington Post now I know a lot of
Trump supporters because they feel like
stopping the left is the top priority
are going to shrug at all Cheney's
criticisms but here is the reality the
reality is that some of those criticisms
are legitimate just as some of and
Coulter's criticisms are legit you can
have it both ways you can have it both
ways way one must oppose the left maybe
that means voting for president Trump
way too president Trump needs to do a
better job less tweeting about airplanes
more wall building for example okay in
just a second Don gets a Tucker Carlson
who is battling back against Media
Matters we'll get to that in just a
second first I need you to go check out
daily wire and subscribe when you do so
much good stuff for you $9.99 a month
get to a subscription to daily wire calm
that comes along with an additional two
hours a day of my radio show you also
get to ask me questions during the
breaks if news breaks you're getting the
latest on all of it I mean we are we are
just putting our shoulder to the
grindstone for you and all you have to
do to be part of it is spend $9.99 a
month or 99 bucks a year for 99 bucks a
year you can get all of those
aforementioned glory's plus the leftist
here's how Durrell called tumblr we're
on the road so that you know what that
means we have activated the invisibility
cloak advice for thee for thee leftist
here's hot or cold tumblr
I know I know Colton I know you're
holding it over there well done Colton
once again shining star of the day in
any case in any case go check out daily
wire com subscribe right now also be
sure to join us tomorrow for daily wire
backstage March Madness edition daily
where god king jeremy boring me and
reclaim the execrable michael moles and
alicia Kraus will be here to cover the
ever-growing cultural political insanity
of today I believe we forced Michael
Mo's to go watch Captain Marvel so he
should have his assessment of Captain
Marvel as only Daily wire subscribers
get to ask the questions to make sure
that you subscribe today also go check
us out at YouTube or iTunes please
subscribe leave us a review we always
we're the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
see I mean we and it's great because we
just deactivated the cloaking device for
this for this tumbler so it's how it
works on the road guys it's an
incredible thing well see you get
through TSA with with just ease of ease
of movement ok so Tucker Carlson has
been attacked of course by media matters
they came out with a second spate of bad
things Tucker Carlson said back in 2007
when I say bad things I don't mean to
say that they are not bad things they
are indeed bad things the Tucker Carlson
said back in 2007 he talked about how
Iraqis were he suggested that they were
illiterate monkeys or something like
that and he was and he dropped an f-bomb
this f-bomb not not the the curse word
but the the f-word that is a slower for
gay people he did all of this in these
silly appearances on the Bubba the Love
Sponge Show and as I said yesterday two
things can be true once one Tucker
Carlson said some stuff I don't like and
I think his ugly back in 2006-2007 stuff
that I find morally reprehensible also a
world in which we are digging up old
stuff that people said and then trying
to ruin them for it is an ugly world and
many of the people who are pretending to
be outraged at Tucker Carlson's comments
are not in fact outraged at Tucker
Carlson's comments many of them are
actually quite excited by Tucker
Carlson's comments being unearthed so
they can go after his advertisers today
here's what a good-faith discussion of
Tucker Carlson's old comments would look
like Tucker Carlson we came up with this
old audio do you still agree with this
do you regret having said this Tucker
Carlson probably said something like
yeah I probably shouldn't said all that
stuff I don't agree with any of that
stuff I was on a shock jock radio show
get over the fact that it's a shock jock
radio shock jock radio existed in the
2000s and the game of shock jock radio
was to say the most shocking thing to
the shock jock that was the game of
shock jock radio right that's just the
reality of the situation that's how a
good-faith conversation would go but
that's not how the conversation actually
goes today the way the conversation
actually goes is that people who want
Tucker Carlson off the air going spend a
hundred hours unearthing a bad stuff the
Tucker Carlson said that nobody
remembers and that no one cared about at
the time and then they bring it back so
that some people earnestly become
outraged and then most people in the
political space are not outraged but say
the Tucker Carlson should have to pay
the price for the stuff that he said ten
years ago
so his advertisers today on Fox News who
have nothing
to do what those old comments should be
punished this is this is the move that
is being made today and it's ugly and
it's gross and as I have said before I
think that it is bad whether it is
applied to Sara John of the New York
Times and whether it is applied to Kevin
Hart the the black comedian who is
ousted from the Oscars or whether this
is applied to pretty much anybody I
don't like the idea of ruining people's
careers based on old stuff that they've
said now if you want to ask them about
it and then they reopen talk about
whether there should be repercussions or
if for example you know they say
something new today like Roseanne Barr
said something new right that's a new
thing she said so we get to react in
real time to what she said but we don't
get to do is look for excuses to be
upset about stuff that was said 20 years
ago without considering the possibility
that maybe who said in a different
context in a society that didn't mind
incendiary things being said quite as
much or the idea that perhaps this
person doesn't agree with stuff that
they said a while ago because people
change their minds on things well one of
the one of the more amusing aspects of
this is watching these so-called
objective media simply rip their masks
off and go full-scale Dracula on Tucker
Carlson I mean climb through his bedroom
window and try to sink those fangs in
Chris Cuomo and John lemon very
objective news journalism over on CNN
they say that really Tucker deserves
this because after all Tucker doesn't
tell the truth on a daily basis so that
means that Tucker deserves anything he
gets if we make a mistake or if we say
something that's controversial and we
want to stand by it we back it up with
the facts behind it right this is why we
said it you may not like it you may
think it's biased whatever these are the
facts as journalists we have to give you
the facts here's my thing we're all on
television live with no filter many
times there's nothing in that camera no
words and we all screw up and we say
dumb things but when you do when
something becomes a pattern and you
don't tell the truth on a daily basis
that's a problem okay but that's not
what we're talking about here we're not
talking about Tucker said something in
real-time now and he screwed up and then
he apologized for what we're talking
about Tucker said something back when
George W Bush was president and he's not
apologizing for it now because he
understands that an apology will be
taken as a sign of weakness and then
people will simply use it as a way to
clap him over the head look even Tucker
realizes he said something very very bad
because
the next step as I have said repeatedly
on this program the next step is never
oh he apologized for it I guess we'll
move on the next step from the left is
typically oh he said that he apologized
for it that means he acknowledges it was
bad he never should have made the
mistake in the first place he never
should have said that bad thing let's
punish him now since he wasn't punished
then being retro retro actively
punishing people for stuff that they
said fifteen years ago that they
disagree with now is pretty insane it
really is pretty wild and again what we
have right now in our society is not a
shortage of outrage we have a surplus of
outrage so a lot of people who are
saying things like well I'm outraged now
about stuff that Tucker said okay you
can be outraged you can be outraged but
let's not pretend that this is not
mostly manufactured outrage for a
political end so I was asked today you
know when it came to Ralph Northam there
was very little consideration of a
friend of mine asked me this on the left
and she asked okay well Ralph Northam
governor of Virginia who was it was an
old yearbook photo of him was unearthed
in which there was a guy in blackface
and a guy in a KKK outfit was honored by
big league politics which is a
right-wing sort of radical right site so
why weren't people asking about their
motivations and unearthing this stuff as
opposed to this case where we are where
we've gone hard after media matters
because Media Matters is in fact a 501 C
3 organization specifically dedicated to
destroying anyone on the right there are
a couple reasons why this is different
reason number one reason number one
Ralph Northam is an elected official
opposition research is regularly done on
elected officials it is supposed to give
more information to the voters so we
don't tend to look at the motivations of
the people uncovering that stuff we
understand that Apple research is a
regular part of politics Apple research
is not the same thing when it comes to
the world of media this notion that
you're going to uncover everything bad
that George Stephanopoulos has ever done
and then use it to destroy him it's
considered more of an attempt to invade
a private person's business than it is
anything else
secondly Media Matters bills itself as
an objective uncover of news and media
watchdog that's not that's how what they
do instead they cover for folks on the
Left they said that nobody should go
after joy read for exactly the same kind
of stuff and they tried to ruin people
on the right and more importantly they
try to ruin the advertisers that are
tangentially associated with people on
whose shows they are advertising
that wrecks the entire industry that is
ramifications far beyond here's a
politician who did a bad thing now what
should the politician do okay so we're
gonna get to Tucker's response here in
in just one second first I would note
that Chris Cuomo again so much objective
journalism he comes out he says Tucker
Carlson is a coward he says Tucker
doesn't count now what makes Tucker a
coward
it makes Tucker a coward that Tucker
hasn't doubled down on his old
statements
why would Tucker double down on his old
statements he said them on a shock jock
radio show I don't know that Tucker
agrees with them we'll get to Tucker's
response in just a second but here's
very objective journalism in block of
wood dumber Cuomo brother Chris Cuomo on
CNN suggesting the Tucker Carlson is a
coward because he wants to catch him to
catch 22 the catch-22 is if Tucker
apologizes it's because Tucker is evil
and if Tucker doesn't apologize it's
because Tucker is evil here's Chris
Cuomo making that case a lot of this
stuff that's coming up at least about
Carlson is from years ago when he was
desperate for attention here's the test
would he say the same things today
no no he's too busy playing the victim
he'd only say that he was naughty but he
wouldn't repeat them tonight why not
come on big man read the list of all the
things that you said and do it again and
show that you mean it come on you're not
more about the money now than you are
about the truth or are you he says
apologizing to the mob costs people
their jobs what a coward
okay what why is that cowardly that is
true apologizing to the mob very often
does cost people their jobs apologizing
to people you've hurt is one thing
apologizing to a bunch of folks on
Twitter who don't give a damn that's
another if they want to point to the
person like here's for example he made
some comments about a guy named Warren
Jeffs Warren Jeffs was convicted of
facilitating rape and Tucker made some
comments about how this guy was not
actually guilty of facilitating rape now
if member vicked UM's of Warren Jeffs
came for and said that's really
offensive to me and Tucker then came for
an apologize to them that's it that is a
discrete victim to whom Tucker
presumably owes an apology but if it's
just some Rando at Media Matters who
hates Tucker Carlson and wants an
apology from him on a daily basis that's
silly and that's basically what Tucker
said Tucker gave him on a log last night
he said you know what I'd offer an
explanation or an apology but I know
that the people who are coming after me
don't care
an explanation or apology and listen I'm
not in the business of questioning
people's motives but when it comes to
media matters I don't have to question
their motives they've made them
absolutely clear when it comes to people
like Chris Cuomo do you think Chris
Cuomo is really angry that Tucker
Carlson said the stuff in 2007 or is he
gleeful that now this stuff has been
uncovered those two clips of Chris Cuomo
and Don Lemon and Chris Cuomo alone
demonstrate the truth
they think the tucker carlson is a bad
guy and a liar and so they are happy
this stuff came up you think Tucker owes
Chris Cuomo an apology why if so why
anyway here was Tucker's response one of
the only places left in the United
States where independent thoughts are
allowed is right here the opinion ours
on this network just a few hours in a
sea of television programming it's not
much relatively speaking for the left
it's unacceptable they demand total
conformity Fox News is behind us as they
have been since the very first day
toughness is a rare quality the TV
network and we are grateful for that
we've always apologized when we're wrong
and will continue to do that that's what
decent people do they apologize but we
will never bow to the mob ever okay and
that seems like an appropriate response
right there that last that last point is
an appropriate response you apologize
when you're wrong I have a running list
on my website daily wire of all the dumb
bad things I've ever said I've issued
apologies directly to people who I feel
like I have offended to who I have
wronged because not just about them
being offended it's about me doing
something wrong I've apologized to lots
of people in my time but I'm not going
to apologize to Media Matters for
anything those people can go take a long
walk off a short pier
to use the clean version of what I would
say and again there is an agenda here
there is in fact an agenda here and you
can see the agenda and it's not just
restricted to media matters there's an
attempt by some folks on the left -
still voices that they simply don't like
I'll give you another example so there's
an interview on a podcast called the
recode decode between Kara Swisher of
recode and Susan watch kicky of YouTube
she's the CEO of YouTube now I've
invited Miss wash Kiki on my Sunday
special she has not responded I don't
expect her to respond I'd be surprised
if she does be more than happy to have
her
we've asked on Jack Dorsey on our Sunday
special the head of Twitter he has said
that he has not had time he's had time
to
though gets mosquito bitten in in a
random cave in Malaysia but but showing
up on one of the biggest podcast in
America not so much to answer some tough
questions in any case this exchange is
pretty telling so Kara Swisher is a far
leftist and she she's very angry
apparently that her son likes to watch
our videos shout out to karel swish her
son how's it gone how everything's going
well thanks for listening Karis which
are very very angry that her son listens
to the show and in fact goes too far so
far as to suggest that perhaps YouTube
should change her to algorithms so that
her son shouldn't be able to find our
videos or perhaps we should even be
kicked off of YouTube my son 13 years
old yeah started watching ben shapiro
videos and he's like the gateway drug to
the next group and then it goes right to
jordan peterson then it goes down and in
three clicks he was at neo-nazi stuff it
was like astonishing and then i had to
listen to it at dinner and then i've got
like this kid who's like well ben
shapiro sort of smart I'm like no he
thought lately he's clever but he's an
idiot and anyway it's just like it's
exhausting but it has like a huge effect
on them there's a set of content that
has to meet the community guidelines ben
shapiro is gonna meet the community
guidelines so yeah I don't think you're
suggesting that we remove him from the
platform are you I would but I can't I
would but I can't yeah that tells you
everything that you need to know about a
lot of the folks on the left I would but
I can't and so people try to find other
ways of knocking people offline they try
to find other ways of downgrading they
try to find excuses to say that certain
videos don't meet community guidelines
on YouTube or that Facebook ought to
downgrade particular content or that
advertisers want to pull off of programs
the left isn't interested at least many
on the radical left are not interested
in an exchange of free and open exchange
of ideas they are interested in shutting
down those ideas I'll be at University
of Michigan tonight the history
department at the University of Michigan
is putting on some sort of counter
events to my event at the University of
Michigan
something about dilettante and history
and the power of the Enlightenment I
mean this is the actual title of what
they are talking about it let me let me
find the exact title of the panel the
panel is titled something like when
provocateurs dabble in history ben
shapiro and the Enlightenment featuring
speakers and panelists responding to my
attacks on campuses in
along with my new history book the right
side of history how reason and moral
purpose made the West great go buy it
right now it's surging up the up the
charts as we speak I'm not sure how
they're gonna critique my book it's not
out till next week I don't know that
they have an advance copy if they do I'd
wonder how and why they wanted one but
it is demonstrative of the fact they
don't actually want to have a discussion
they could just show up to my discussion
and then they could ask questions we
could have a respectful conversation in
fact some of the folks who are speaking
at this thing sound like they've done
interesting work so I frankly kind of
want to hear from Dean angela Diller for
example she wrote a book about
multicultural conservatism I think it
could be kind of interesting but instead
they've decided to directly
counter-program my speech because they
don't want people showing up to my
speech fortunately nobody cares the way
they have like 31 RSVPs and we have 4200
people on a waitlist for an event that
already has 1200 people coming but the
bottom line is this for too many folks
on the left this is true of media
matters it's true of a lot of the tech
companies they're more interested in
shutting down other sides of the debate
than they aren't actually having the
discussion and if they can't do it by
simply doing it directly instead they
will seek other excuses that means
digging up everything all that you've
ever said and trying to destroy you with
it these are people who are looking to
hurt you these aren't people who are
looking to purify the public debate
tucker made a point he said listen at
least the old Puritans wanted to purify
the public space the left doesn't want
to purify the public space they just
want to get rid of people with whom they
disagree okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like there's a new version
of Papillon the movie that originally
features Steve McQueen and Dustin
Hoffman the new version is fine it's
okay and it Charlie Hunnam stars in the
in the title role and rami malek stars
as Louie daga who is sort of the the
forager for folks who don't remember the
story of happy on there is supposedly
the story's probably mostly fiction
there was a a guy who was convicted of
murder and was sent to devil if to
French Guiana and then to Devil's Island
and he escaped after a bunch of years
and ended up writing a best-selling book
about all of this that became a movie
with Steve McQueen and Dustin Hoffman's
I could recommend the one with Charlie
Hunnam and rami malek but it's mostly
just okay instead I'll recommend the
original with Steve McQueen and Dustin
Hoffman here's a little bit of that
trailer
after five years as an international
bestseller it comes to the screen
unquestionably the greatest adventure of
escape ever filmed Steve McQueen Dustin
Hoffman
Papillon
[Music]
first of all I'll point out that Steve
McQueen and Dustin Hoffman is a better
combo than Charlie Hunnam and rami malek
rami malek is is it mandated that he be
in every movie now apparently it is
mandatory that rami malek be cast in
every single movie filmed so I'm not
sure what part he plays in in the new
Captain Marvel but I assume we'll see
him in there similar the the movie is
worth watching the original and again
the remake is not bad it's just not the
original okay time for a thing that I
hate so I made fun of USC a little bit
earlier the truth is USC is a wonderful
University and there are a lot of great
students who go to USC my sister went to
USA there's a horrible story coming out
of the area around USC this is from the
San Francisco Chronicle reporting the
son of Oakland City Councilwoman Lynette
Gibson McElhaney was fatally shot early
Sunday in Los Angeles Victor McElhaney
and Oakland native was a student at the
University of Southern California the
avid drummer and jazz musician had
recently transferred to the University
from Cal State East Bay McElhaney
apparently was the victim of an
attempted robbery off campus because the
area around USC is extraordinarily
unsafe LA area media outlets reported
that McElhaney was approached by several
males at the corner of Maple Avenue and
Adams Boulevard one of them shot Mac
Eleni before the group fled in a vehicle
a sergeant at the LAPD's Newton station
which respondents the incidents a client
provide further details Lynette Gibson
McElhaney called her son's death a
senseless act of violence
she said Victor was a son of Oakland he
was a musician who drew his inspiration
from the beat soul and sound of the town
he belongs in every nook and cranny of
Oakland I miss my baby please keep me my
family and all of my son's friends in
your thoughts and prayers now I know
that Victor Mecca Laney was a delightful
person because he was until I actually
had the chance to meet him so when I was
at USC I spoke there just a few months
ago and Victor McIlhenny unlike a lot of
the people who decided to stand outside
and protest actually came and asked a
question and we had a really nice
exchange whose really genial I thought
he was generous of spirit the world
needs more people like Victor Mak Eleni
here was a little bit of our exchange hi
so you have given a number of speeches
about the difference between opportunity
and outcome and you
that our country has no lack of
opportunity correct equal access to
rights I think might be the better way
to state it yeah okay so equal I'm
saying okay
equal access to the exercises right so
you're correct that I've said
opportunity before it's not exact enough
so I'm modifying it now okay because
when I say because with it because
obviously that's a forecast where this
conversation is going to go but but I
have a feeling where you're going to go
and you can correct me if I'm wrong I'll
give you plenty of time is is that what
you're gonna say is that not everybody
has equal opportunity which of course is
true not everybody some people are rich
some people are poor some people are
smart some people are stupid but
everyone does have equal access to
rights
[Applause]
/ sir and then the exchange went on for
several minutes really nice guy you can
see he's really good natured and curious
and questioning real loss to the United
States real loss to the world the death
of a victor mecha Lanie again crime
ought to be policed criminals ought to
be tracked down I only hope that his
murderers are caught and punished to the
fullest extent of the law it's really
heartbreaking
we need more conversations we need more
people who are open-minded and
open-hearted and Victor mecha Laney was
apparently one of those people I was
just informed that that he was the
person I spoke to at the speech last
night by a fellow member of the USC
community so my heart my heart goes out
to his family and really I'm pretty
upset about it as I think everybody
everybody who's a good-hearted person
should be already well we will be back
here a little bit later but if you want
to access that you're gonna have to go
over to Daley wire comm and become a
subscriber also today would be a good a
good day to pre-order my book the right
side of history before it is all sold
out at your local bookstore or on Amazon
go check it out right now searching up
the bestseller charts it comes out next
week I'm looking forward to talking
about it then and we'll see you here
later this afternoon i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19